c'est la dernière passe d'armes entre
les états unis et la chine
ce mercredi washington a ordonné la
fermeture du consulat chinois à houston
afin de protéger la propriété
intellectuelle américaine selon des
médias locaux des documents auraient été
brûlés dans des poubelles de la cour de
l'antenne diplomatique texane les
pompiers se serait même vu refuser
l'accès lorsqu'ils ont tenté d'entrer
dans le bâtiment
les etats unis accusent pékin de s'être
livrée par le passé à un espionnage
massive sur son sol et de s'être mêlé 2
politique intérieure le président trump
a dit ça suffit nous n'allons pas
permettre que cela se produise à nouveau
vous avez vu les remarques du conseiller
à la sécurité nationale o brien du
directeur du fbi à ivry du procureur
général bart nous avons défini des
attentes claires quant à la manière dont
le parti communiste chinois devrait se
comporter et lorsqu'ils ne le fera pas
nous adopterons des mesures pour
protéger le peuple américain
notre sécurité notre sécurité nationale
et aussi notre économie et nos emplois
ce sont les mesures que vous voyez le
président trump adopté et nous
continuerons à le faire
de son côté la chine affirme avoir été
forcé par les états unis à fermer son
consulat houston une décision qualifiée
de provocation politique ton emphatique
il s'agit d'une provocation politique
unilatérale contre la chine les etats
unis ont gravement violé le droit
international et les normes
fondamentales des relations
internationales ils ont également
gravement violé le traité consulaire ce
sabotage intentionnelle des relations
bilatérales et scandaleux la chine le
condamne fermement et exhorte les états
unis de ne pas fermer le consulat
auquel cas nous prendrons rapidement des
mesures nécessaires et légitimes y aura
la veille m'a pompé au en visite à
londres avait salué l'exclusion du géant
chinois huawei du réseau 5g britannique
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
avait aussi exhorté le monde à faire
front contre la chine
nous voulons que chaque nation travail
contre ce genre d'activités ce sont des
actions
ce n'est pas une question de langage ce
ne sont pas des mots nous voulons que
chaque nation de travail ensemble pour
faire barrage au parti communiste
chinois dans toutes les dimensions que
je vous ai décrit aujourd'hui
cela inclut certainement le royaume uni
la loi controversée sur la sécurité
nationale entrée en vigueur à hong kong
le traitement de la minorité oui cours
ainsi qu les revendications
territoriales de pékin en mer de chine
ou encore les tensions commerciales
récurrente les points de friction entre
washington et pékin ne cessent de
s'accumuler depuis plusieurs mois